[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
weihnachten steht vor der tür
es duftet überall nach glühwein und zimt
in der zürcher st jakobs stiftung werden
heute kurz lege backen für das fest der
liebe und um die liebe
in vielen facetten geht es heute auch in
kultur platz feiern sie mit
[Musik]
ja weihnachten das fest der liebe steht
vor der tür da haben wir uns gedacht wir
lassen sie heute schon rein und wir sind
zu gast an einem ort da wird die
nächstenliebe gelebt und das riecht erst
noch nach frischem brot
[Musik]
die zürcher stiftung sankt jakob bietet
menschen mit beeinträchtigung seit mehr
als 100 jahren ausbildung und arbeit und
werde ich mich hier heute in der
backstube nützlich machen
lernen sie paar und deren rezepte für
die liebe kennen
[Musik]
ich mache mich hier jetzt bereit für
meinen einsatz in der backstube und die
montur die ich mir gleich anziehen darf
die hat nichts mit corona zu tun sondern
natürlich mit den hygienemaßnahmen in
der bäckerei aber zurück zur liebe
unter dieser wunderbaren haube eher eine
theoretische vorstellung aber egal
alle sprechen ja von ihr aber kaum
jemand kennt ihr geheimnis was ist sie
denn pure chemie komplett überbewertet
oder gar etwas göttliches und was
braucht sie damit sie bleibt wir haben
drei paare nach ihren liebes rezepten
gefangenen gewusst wie
und die liebe kann so einfach sein
[Musik]
was liebe ist versucht auch ein neues
schweizer buch zu ergründen 300
künstlerinnen und künstler geben darin
in text und bild antworten das ist
poetisch und anregend und bleibt dennoch
theorie in der praxis
da wissen sie wie es geht pascal
wiedemann und daniel mettler sind seit
20 jahren ein künstler und ehepaar ein
paar das unterschiedlicher nicht sein
könnte dafür ergänzen sie sich bestens
in ihrer aktuellen arbeit lovers lane
fahrt der liebenden verbinden sich
daniels fotografien und pascals malerei
zu einem stimmungsvollen gesamtwerk
gemeinsam kunst zu machen dass erhält
ihren liebesrausch
kunst kann natürlich denn wir viel über
nee ich glaube sowieso der erste sturm
vor der größte verlierer ist kunst
erzeugt selber schaffen erzeugt
ähnliches gefühl wie verliebt sie
ich stelle fest dass wir mehr kunst
machen
sie seien offen und beweglich und
veränderten sie ständig sagen die beiden
den anderen verändern zu wollen sei
hingegen ein liebeskiller sowie solide
hilfe ist es natürlich merke dass man
möglichst probierte an der slowenisch
und natürlich auch oft vom partner dass
der trainer selber ist es offiziell als
geheimrezept ein allgemeingültiges
rezept gibt es nicht wer im buch der
liebe blättert findet die
verschiedensten facetten farben und
formen
holly und eric ambler leben seit bald
vier jahrzehnten zusammen auf ihrem
kleiner hai mit li ein bescheidenes
leben eine berührende liebesgeschichte
[Musik]
heribert war mit 40 jahren des
alleinseins unter vielen arbeit auf
seinem hof müde und suchte eine frau und
das im schweizer fernsehen
in der sendung karussell gab es schon
1983 die rubrik bauer sucht bäuerin und
heiri fand unter den 20 bewerberinnen
seine erika eine 25-jährige metzgerei
verkäuferin aus der tour genommen
bald schon läuteten die hochzeitsglocken
und es kamen zwei kinder
[Musik]
36 arbeit seiner jahre später haben die
blass den bauernbetrieb aufgegeben
ihre liebe aber die blüht noch immer die
liebe hat sich verändert und die
sexualität ist nicht mehr so wichtig wie
am anfang
[Musik]
vor kurzem sind die großeltern geworden
das verbindet zusätzlich ein wunsch aber
bleibt und nicht zu vergessen georgia
und hat
seit 20 jahren ein paar leben sie in
einer eingetragenen partnerschaft bei
ihnen sind es die gemeinsamkeiten ihre
technischen berufe die sie zusammen
schweißen
der wahnsinn ja gesagt ich bin ingenieur
ich habe das ist was ich suche vor lange
zeit und dann habe ich gedacht gleich
interesse gleichen gefühle und einer ja
das ist wirklich echte liebe was löste
george in mir aus ja geborgenheit und
zuneigung und vertrauen
irgendwie so dass es die basis von
meinem leben
hans und giorgio reisen oft machen
vieles gemeinsam eine symbiose es ist
interessant manchmal kommen sie genau
die gleiche fort da zusammen
ich weiß nicht warum wird denn manchmal
das gleiche das ist erstaunlich oder das
ist so ja genau das wollte ich jetzt
auch gerade sagen wo für mich passt
einfach also für mich nichts liebe wenn
es passt wenn alles passt und wer die
große liebe bis jetzt noch nicht
gefunden hat der kann in der
zwischenzeit im buch der liebe schmökern
[Musik]
lobbyist ein prächtiges buch und weil
wir unser publikum lieben verschenken
wir fünf exemplare davon zu weihnachten
denn da aus dieser bäckerei gibt es noch
obendrauf
[Musik]
genau
ein bisschen überrascht wenig kaffee
team aus dass russische 5 kilogramm
alexander halten sie sind der
geschäftsführer darauf sagt jakob stetig
was wir mit überwinden wir beschäftigen
menschen mit berechtigung die werden
freut behindert sein fachangestellte
ableitet und wie ein 440 menschen krank
sind es wichtig zu wissen dass das ganz
normale personen sind in der einfach mal
bei k
sie bleibe und die heimat über 550 mit
trips irische berechtigung 15 bis 20 an
der name soviel menschen mit
sinnesbehinderungen und den bereich für
jugendliche mit lernschwächen und die
räume tattoos und mehr der mit den
produkthersteller wofür beherrschte
arbeitsmarkt relevant sind
das habe ich große tradition hat das
überhaupt alles angefangen
das ist sie in münster 2 durch marie
wirklich sehr innovativ sie sich
lehrerin zehn blindow schulen und hätten
auch eine gesetzes die blinde bauer nach
einer eigentlich auf der straße gelandet
sind nach dem schulabschluss und den
heizungs ab wie sich die beschäftigen
und hat mit denen er hat gleich drei auf
tour und das ist der ursprung für unsere
stiftung
sie führen dass unternehmer wenn es
konventionell so unternahmen auch
wirtschaftlichen kriterien logisch wie
geht das zusammen mit dem bedürfnis von
mitarbeitern leistungsfähigkeit vor
seiner mitarbeiter die spät prächtig
aber qualität und die größte freude
machen ist wenn den grund und namhafte
marken wie die schweiz mit dieser
mannschaft glück kann der marke schaffen
können um amerika ein konzept einig für
seine firma bisher stellen und das ist
die spreu turnieren bereitet ich hoffe
es alles sehr entscheidend dass wir
einen selbstwert der fahrer bin schaffen
wir unsere tätigkeit etwas anzieht auch
für erfahrungen mit ihren mitarbeiten
sehr erfolgreich sei wenn man einfach
einen duft wo es probleme während die
person weiter entwickeln wie zum
beispiel lernen der lokalen den
jugendkader herzproblem kann mit
suchterkrankungen schaffe ich aus dem
sucht tv st
er hätte fahrwerk macht
noch ein weiterer impulsgeber bis zu
meiner abschluss mit eidgenössischem
fachausweis und technik sind kanton und
den ersten arbeitsmarkt
[Musik]
hier sehen wir in der confiserie der
zürcher st jakobs stiftung und von hier
aus schauen wir rüber ins zürcher museum
für gestaltung dort wird am freitag eine
neue ausstellung eröffnet
es geht um die liebe zur mode und diese
ausstellung stellt unter beweis dass die
schweizer modeszene durchaus das zeug
hat zu einem wild
[Musik]
also schweizer mode
im unterschied zum pariser mode oder ein
modus mailand sitzt ihr spitzenmodells
ohne man verliert sich dann immer
schnell in klischees darum ist es
offiziell
dann zu frau maya schweizer models
typisieren beschrieben oder vielleicht
sogar kritisiere gottes hand schlecht
karin gewagt sie trotzdem die einordnung
der schweizer mode und dies obwohl es
die schweizer mode nicht zu geben
scheint keine gemeinsame formsprache
keine helvetische fashion dna kein
wunder sagt die erfahrene kuratorin
denn die bedingungen seien hierzulande
alles andere als ideal
die hand kann er also mode die hand
letztlich wahrscheinlich an ihres königs
oscar i han kyoung rote teppich mit
antalya ort wo so mode
der glamour-faktor ko spiele hits wie
sie die schweiz nicht und ist das
problem nie behauptet die deren stelle
ich eigentlich nicht mehr behalten
das ist ein vorteil das sieht dann so
aus an elf stationen sind die stücke von
50 einheimischen designerinnen und
designern zu sehen
hier wird klar mode will über
traditionen neu nachdenken
mode kann den wunsch nach
gesellschaftlicher veränderung
transportieren
indem sie zb den trend zur fluiden
geschlechtsidentität aufnimmt auf den
punkt bringt es diese videoarbeit darin
ein jeans look für einen das modische
meisterstück von jetzt will nicht
einfach den sack und lumpi sondern es
muss mit denen mit der unentschiedenheit
spiele mit diesem ausloten der grenzen
bereichern die kreativen die öffentliche
debatte
auch hier umfangreichen bekannt ist dass
die papst des landes sieht die große
stärke der schweizer mode in der
auseinandersetzung mit
gesellschaftlichen phänomen gender thema
pop kulturen zu ritter des grund sollen
der kollektion zum beispiel bietet
suisse geht und dass fans dann
allerdings ein kleiderständer landet das
heißt im lager amtsleiter buckel und
verkauft werde muss das ist doch wie
bisher sich viele designer schwerte und
der mittelweg zwischen zwischen drei
eigene anschrift zwischen fällig da
zieht geist abbilden und kommerz das
zeigt sich schon 1997 damals
veranstaltet das landesmuseum zürich die
letzte schau zur aktuellen schweizer
mode
[Musik]
na ja das ist das erste was trieb
themen sind die gleiche bleiben also die
mangelnde akzeptanz im inland die die
ignoranz vielleicht vom konsument
gespräches auf stupides versager von der
branche zum besser auf sich aufmerksam
machen mode medien switzerland gilt
immer noch als nischenprodukt ein
hauptgrund dafür ist der aufschwung von
h&m zara und co
und dem damit verbundenen niedergang des
preisniveaus viele designerinnen und
designer können mehr schlecht als recht
von ihren kollektionen leben
akris agiert als international
erfolgreichstes ethisches modehaus
ausgerechnet der primus der branche habe
die auswirkungen der pandemie aber
massiv zu spüren bekommen so karin gummi
sich kritisch mit dem material rolle hat
nena liefere genau in dem moment wo sie
ihre kollektionen hätte müsse machen und
das hat zur folge dass mir die stücke
gerne hättet überhand wie die geht's
einfach nur einmal und die hand nicht
wissen zur verfügung gestellt werden
der einzige big player der schweizer
modeszene fehlt das ist verkraftbar
denn erst damit ist karin gemäss idee
ganz konsequent umgesetzt den kleinen
lebens den großen auftritt zu
verschaffen damit er fasst die
ausstellung das wesen der schweizer mode
sie ist halt ein nächstes aber
unbezahlbares wild say ein wildes ding
[Musik]
danke
das ist
ein bisschen zu tun ist
[Musik]
ja und wenn wir heute wird hier bereitet
machen wir jetzt nicht zehn sterne
sondern
[Musik]
kraft
sie zeigt irgendeinen usa massiv druck
dem kurzen privat dann können die augen
du hast ganz spezielle also das mit dem
wasser also das mittel ausmachen
[Musik]
wir warten also auch die zimt herzen und
zeigen ihnen währenddessen die gewinner
des wettbewerbs von letzter woche
kunstschaffen der kulturschaffende der
projekte in der schublade liegen wegen
corona die konnten sich ja bei uns
melden und hier sind die ersten gewinner
im porträt den und grad
[Musik]
bühne frei für daniela den florian sears
und christoph mutig und hongkong
kletterten
also das war nicht vom rad
die drei kennen sich zwar schon lange
als open world music formation gibt es
hier aber erst seit letztem jahr mit dem
achten abstieg
[Musik]
das hätte gefährlich stresst das hat
jetzt eine herbstbelebung oder er
probiert sich frau mit seine stärkste
waffe zurückzuerobern
mit dem ratschlag
[Musik]
es ist konzept gegen den clowns also
mehr an dringend empfohlen das ist immer
alles glänzt alles auf der bühne ist
sowieso der perfektionismus der klient
gegen wird mit monitoren danach erwartet
das nicht immer bis bis zum perfekten
schnitte und der improvisation so gut
dass mögliche umgehe
bis vor wenigen wochen durften dill und
kraut noch auftreten wenn auch unter
ausnahmebedingungen 70
[Musik]
auflage von igor und fit
jetzt wird halt nur noch geprobt im wort
stellwerk dem jungen schreibhaus in
basel wo die forschung forciert der
schmuck präsentiert und die kunst
konsumiert wird wo die brücken
verstrickt die bäume verpackt und die
klicken im takt sind sind viele
irritationen
ganz stark mit dem alltag stuhl sind
wortspiel wovon die idee bringen sind
vor allem sportlerin inspiration also
wenn mehrere so auf den wiederholungen
mit buches so viel floskel mehr sind als
dann will ich gar nicht bewusst und und
damit aufgriff und und verarbeitet und
auf bühne bringen kann vielleicht die
absurdität der präsenz nächstes jahr
wollen till und kraut wie das schweizer
kleinkunst bühnen bespielen
bis dahin bleibt viel zeit zum texten
tüfteln
wenn sie
für uns denken wir uns einschränken was
die grenzen zufrieden
er lebt in der schweiz
die besten 30 der besten wert zu sein
und die ordnung steht bei ihr und ihren
sind passiert die menschen sagt probiert
[Musik]
doch so schön sind die
diese woche hätten ihnen bern die
kulturhäuser wieder aufmachen sollen
theater konzerte kino alle waren sie
bereit doch der kanton hat anders
entschieden der vorhang bleibt zu wie
das ist in den startlöchern zu stehen
und nicht auftreten zu können
wir haben uns in vernum gehört der
goldene fuß gehört zu dantes göttlicher
komödie ein stück das bisher nicht
stattfinden konnte das konzert theater
bern ist geschlossen
auch wenn hinter den kulissen alles
bereit stehen würde
olaf schmidt ist chef disponent des vier
sparten hauses von woche zu woche plant
er immer wieder neu 155 vorstellungen
musste er schon streichen doch diese
woche hätten endlich wieder stücke
aufgeführt werden sollen ab dem 8
dezember hätten wir wieder spielen
dürfen dann hätten wir eine fledermaus
premiere gehabt im großen haus wir
hätten eine zweite vorstellung
fledermaus gehabt werden den der goalie
bilyk unser erfolgsprogramm als
wiederaufnahme gesehen und in der wipper
zwei unserer kleinen spielstätte noch
zwei premieren das heißt also was uns
fehlt sind vier premieren und eine
wiederaufnahme trotz erneuter
verschiebung der premieren es wird
weiter geprobt
hier ist es michael endes stück momo es
handelt von der suche nach der
gestohlenen zeit passen zu diesem jahr
[Musik]
die menschen fühlen sich immer immer
lehrer erinnern
der betrieb läuft doch wie lange lässt
sich das hinziehen würden bilder werden
angefertigt kostüme werden genäht
planungen gehen weiter
es wird geprobt et cetera also unser
betrieb ist jetzt leider fürs publikum
so als spielort nicht wahrnehmbar aber
es ist ein betrieb der bereit ist sobald
es wieder losgehen kann auch wieder
loszulegen
die schauspielerinnen schlüpfen immer
wieder in neue rollen spielen ohne zu
wissen wann es wieder vor publikum sein
wird florentine kraft probt schon ihr
drittes stück das längst auf der bühne
zu sehen sein sollte ich habe wie gesagt
vier mal gespielt dann haben wir network
im gleich im anschluss geprobt das haben
wir auch nur bis zur generalprobe
gemacht und das liegt jetzt in der
schublade
und jetzt sind wir bei fräulein julie in
der gleichen situation das heißt wir
haben echt viel produziert und
irgendwann mache mir wahrscheinlich sind
premieren wochenende und dann hauen wir
ein ding nach dem anderen raus
ein theater ohne publikum da gibt es
auch stau hinter den kulissen neue
bühnenbilder werden fürs nächste jahr
gebaut
gleichzeitig müssen alte wegen schutz
konzepten immer wieder angepasst werden
das war das originalmodell er sieht
jetzt anders aus zum beispiel gibt es
dieses portal was war noch steht das
gibt es gar nicht mehr
also das ist der reduktion zum opfer
gefallen der steg ist ein bisschen
schmaler die treppen sind weiter
vorgezogen sind eigentlich jetzt
mittlerweile hier ein theater und
konzerthaus in völliger schwebe in
diesem jahr wurden schon über 20.000
karten zurückgegeben oder erstattet fürs
jahresende sieht es nicht viel besser
aus
excel listen weit über 60
felix auch kraft die haben jetzt hoffen
wir einfach dass wir spielen dürfen das
wäre nicht so schade weil das da ist
steckt so viel herzblut und so viel
energie dahinter
und das ist dann immer sonne bremser
jahren denke ich jetzt muss es sich doch
entladen bei seiner premiere und dann
ist so
chef disponent schnitt gönnt sich noch
einen kaffee bevor er weiter plant doch
mit den verschärften cockpit maßnahmen
des bundes wird er wohl weitere
vorstellungen streichen müssen
so hat er sich das jahresende nicht
vorgestellt
[Musik]
das war unsere sendungen aus der zürcher
sankt jakob stiftung wo wir teig und
liebe geknetet haben
und wenn man gar nicht aufgeht dann gibt
es immer noch denn glühwein nächste
woche da ziehen wir uns zurück an einen
sehr romantischen platz und gleich jetzt
geht's hier weiter mit der serie ohne
grenzen halten sie sich warm
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen ihr kultur
swisslos